jean françois bonhomme bonjour bonjour
vous avez 57 ans vous êtes directeur
defeat de la fédération des maisons
familiales et rurales de martinique
vous allez vous présenter à
rivière-pilote pour la quatrième fois et
vous allez conduire la liste agir pour
rivière pilote c'est bien cela
c'est bien ce soir pourquoi monsieur
bonhomme vous vous présentez qu'est-ce
qui a fait que vous êtes candidat
aujourd'hui parce que vous aviez décidé
de ne pas conduire de liste vous étiez
dans une démarche d'alliance d'union de
j'ai toujours dit que je ne suis pas
forcément celui qui t'a tête devant
j'avais à partir de 2015
considéré que je pouvais intégrer un
groupe j'ai fait savoir aux uns et aux
autres que je voulais dans un
rassemblement européen
c'était encore j'ai simplement avec
monsieur rugby j'ai repris une réflexion
depuis un an et demi avec mathieu biron
à qui je vais donner ma confiance je le
jeu là fillon je lui avais dit vas-y je
te suivrai et à un moment donné j'avais
fixé la date du 15 janvier pour que le
rassemblement soit complètement établies
de manière transparente de manière
claire malheureusement il n'a fait
savoir ce jour-là qu'il avait décidé de
ne plus être du lys à partir de là je me
suis trouvée libre de ma décision j'ai
mes amis mes amis m'avaient déjà fait
comprendre que en dehors de cette
démarche là avec guillon et ne suivrai
personnes et là le mot était très clair
si tu ne conduit pas thalys nous nions
avec personne sauf que nous avons une
équipe et un groupe qui travaille depuis
six ans
parfois certains sont là depuis 18 ans
nous réfléchissons nous observons la
ville sans faire de vagues en respectant
les uns et les autres et nous avons
décidé unanimement de conduire notre
liste et nous nous constatons que des
personnes nous rejoignent pour nous
accompagner dans cette démarche mais
c'était quand même une alliance le jouet
employer un mot rapide
bizarre ce que vous avez toujours
combattu le mime jeu de billeron lui
était du mime et est toujours du mime
monsieur j'ai toujours dit que je n'ai
aucune espèce de limite ou de barrières
quand il s'agit de travailler ma règle
très simple
ne regardez pas avec qui je parle
écoutez ce que je lui dis ne regardez
pas avec qui je travaille hu a gardé le
voile que nous construisons
rivière-pilote c'est un chantier pour
lequel on a besoin de tout le monde
quelle que soit la couleur politique en
matière de gestion municipale la couleur
politique n'a pas de considération n'a
pas de sens il ya des gens qui ont de la
volonté il ya déjà que du savoir-faire
avec qui on a envie de travailler
je vais considérer parce que depuis très
longtemps nous avons une relation plus
ou moins très respectueux et les gens
vise à aider les autres et j'avais
considéré qu'il y avait dans cette
équipe de ce groupe quelques personnes
avec qui je pouvais travailler
sérieusement
ce n'est pas le cas avec vladimir vivre
c'est pas la même chose ils étaient ils
étaient dans le groupe aussi il était
dans le groupe
vous savez j'ai tendance à ne pas aimer
me mettre derrière les gens qui n'ont
jamais fait leurs preuves
c'est ma tendance je suis très exigeant
vis-à-vis de môme je travaille avec tout
le monde sauf qu'il faut bien montrer ce
que vous pouvez faire et je n'ai pas
cette idée là j'ai pas cette vision là
deuxièmement je dis aussi que pour livia
pilotes
compte tenu des enjeux compte tenu de
l'importance de la tâche à accomplir
on a besoin de tout le monde et c'est
pour cette raison que j'ai rencontré
tous les candidats je me dis et j'ai
toujours dit depuis 2001 ont fait de moi
un candidat obligé je dis à tout le
monde j'ai envie de travailler pour ma
commune je n'ai humaine avec jean le
fumage est le même quel est le problème
du quai les problèmes pourquoi pas quel
est le problème
c'est une gestion municipale vous
travaillez pour un peu pour travailler
pour des gens que des besoins quel est
le problème je suis capable de dire
mettons nous tous de l'eau potable parce
qu'il ya des urgences
il ya des enjeux qui sont extrêmement
importants qui dépasse la couleur
politique
alors on a une minute 1015 quelles sont
les grandes lignes de votre programme
monsieur gm fils qui est en déclin j'ai
une ville qui se meurt un bout qui est
mort je veux relancer cette ville la
part des actions fortes
d'abord sur le plan de l'écologie sur le
plan de la protection du bourg je dis
que nous devons très rapidement nous
mettre autour d'une table avec les
services de l'état les services des
collectivités territoriales et les
services de l'espace sud pour agir pour
le traitement de la protection de l'ape
du bout contre les couilles
nous devons agir rapidement pour prendre
en charge des personnes âgées organiser
une réponse municipale pour les
personnes âgées en accueil de jour en
ehpad où on m'a pas il nous faut une
réponse et je dis qu'il faut faire du
sport
la priorité le deuxième volet de
l'action éducative
parce que cette ville a besoin de
retrouver de l'éclat et cet éclat la
bourse passés à partir du goût à partir
du sport et à partir de l'accompagnement
est la réponse que l'on apprend aux
personnes âgées moi je considère que
vivien pin up aujourd'hui de devenir un
chantier parce que nous sommes une ville
rurale une ville de l'intérieur qui a
tout donné et qui n'a rien reçu il ya
piscine à saint-esprit
il ya eu je veux dire lycée ailleurs et
nous n'avons rien il ya ehpad dans
toutes les communes voisines
nous alimentons tout le monde nous
n'avons rien je veux qu'il y ait une
réponse claire pour le développement de
cette ville et j'appelle tous les
pilotins qui ont envie doit changer quel
que soit leur couleur politique
tous les pilotes qui ont vite travaillé
pour la ville de nous rejoindre et jeudi
au président la collectivité
territoriale président j'ai des idées en
projets pour notre ville tant que
président je te soutiendrai mais deux
mois à développer rivière-pilote parce
que c'est le l'héritage que nous devons
laisser pour la jeunesse vous cherchez
des à être vous ici à des traits à du
départ à monaco mathieu jeune adama le
soutien de personne je suis quelqu'un de
libre indépendant je n'ai besoin de
personne dans un combat politique
françois busnel je vois mieux c'est moi
qui vous remercie et je salue la
population du japon
[Musique]